as the jury in the trial of kyle
rittenhouse deliberated and prepared to
issue a verdict in keeping with our
system of law black lives matter members
decided to put their finger on the
scales of justice if the jurors refused
to sacrifice the obviously innocent
teenager to the mob
[Music]
[Music]
if kenosha don't get it shut it down so
this is about kyle rittenhouse this is
outside the cal rittenhouse trial but
then they start referencing jacob blake
seven shots in the back seven shots in
the back which uh he deserved he
deserved more than that frankly and the
cops i think were lenient with with
jacob blake
but what does this have to do with that
we're talking about a completely
separate incident i suppose the only
thing that has to do with it is that
kyle rittenhouse was present at the
riots that began after the jacob blake
arrest there are two trials going on
here the trial in the court of law and
then this completely unrelated trial in
the court of public opinion the
prosecution already lost on the evidence
and by all rights should lose in the
court of law with regard to kyle
rittenhouse and so the media and its
activists on the ground are going into
overdrive to salvage the case on the
streets i'm michael knowles this is
michael noel's show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
coming yesterday is from tile tile tyler
who says if we weren't already sure we
damn sure know now
quote the good news is we're now the
counterculture when you're in the
counterculture you can't afford to be
lazy says jeremy boring this is very
true
and this is why i think
on the left
that very often the news media the
prosecutors like in the written house
case the politicians they get caught
with their pants down they get caught
unable to answer basic questions they
get caught in foolish errors because
there's no pressure on them
whereas for the right if you are the
counterculture if you're opposing the
ruling class you've got to have
everything absolutely right if you're
kyle rittenhouse you need to make sure
every shot you take is totally
justifiable every move you make is
totally within
the realm of self-defense and even then
they still might throw you to the wolves
speaking of the wolves speaking of
carnivores
i would strongly recommend when you want
the top quality meats you go check out
good ranchers since 2015 over 100 000
independent farms and ranches in the
united states have shut down why because
foreign meat are robbing americans of
their livelihoods and robbing you of
great flavor that's why the good
ranchers are here to support local
american farms and help you make great
american meals
that that product of usa tag has been
stolen by foreign countries they process
their meat here and then label it like
it came from the united states and
because of these
labeling laws that favor foreign
imported meat the american rancher and
the american consumer both get a raw
deal go check out good ranchers they've
got incredible beef wonderful chicken i
love the burgers to me the burgers are
just out of this freaking world go to
goodranchers.com right now
get 10 free bistro fillets and in
addition if you subscribe you will save
25 off each subscription box of
mouth-watering american meats for life
these boxes will show up on schedule
right to your door so right now you'll
get 10 free bistro fillets which is 100
value free express shipping and 25
off your monthly subscription for life
at goodranchers.com knowles that is
goodrangers.com use code knowles at
checkout 10 freebies truffles free
express shipping and 25
off your monthly subscription for life
goodrangers.com
knowles
we have a daily wire reporter on the
ground right now in kenosha our friend
georgia howe
so she showed up to the courthouse she's
interviewing people
about these two
somewhat related but really quite
different cases there's the trial that's
going on of kyle rittenhouse and then
there are people protesting about jacob
blake jacob blake was that degenerate
accused rapist who was reaching into a
car with a weapon refusing resisting
arrest reaching into a car with kids
with a weapon about to drive off with
these kids and finally and only then did
the cops shoot him in the back
and
so there were protests going on about
that incident because that incident
sparked these leftist terrorists to go
out into the street and riot and then
kyle rittenhouse shows up to protect
property to go to this community that he
works in that his father lives in and
there antifa who were showing up on
behalf of the blm people uh threatened
kyle rittenhouse's life and then kyle
rittenhouse fights back so it's these
two really distinct stories but they are
kind of interwoven so georgia
interviewed jacob blake's
uncle
who says that this entire case is all
about
race
now a lot of people have been making
this about race and i noticed we have
some black lives matter protesters here
um do you think this case is about race
of course
i'm going to be just cold-blooded honest
with you of course it is a young black
man was shot seven times in the back who
was never charged with any crime who was
not being aggressive and who had his
back turned on a police officer
now but when it comes to the kyle
rittenhouse case all of the men that he
shot were white so how is that kyle
rittenhouse case about race so to be
blunt with you back in the 50s 40s and
60s they would refer to them as lovers
so they were sacrificed they were
sacrificing this young man was used
so if they can uh what with the tone
that we're setting today is that i don't
believe our uh uh caucasian counterparts
are willing to give up the lives of
their young people on the street this is
no different than the shooting in
colorado the shooting in florida it was
a young person because he would have
been in high school or just out of high
school and he shouldn't have had a gun
not the most coherent or eloquent or
intelligent fellow in the world but but
jacob blake's uncle is saying look it's
true that the people who were killed in
the kyle rittenhouse incident were white
but they were they were really only
killed because they're white people who
like black people
they're they're you know if larry elder
is a is the black face of white
supremacy then that pedophile and the
other people who were killed attacking
kyle rittenhouse they're the white face
of
black victimhood i guess
it's all
anything that works with our left-wing
narrative that's all about
you know we're the wonderful black
victims anything that supports the the
right in america
they are white supremacists even if
they're black
the argument he makes here by the way
about his nephew jacob blake that look
he wasn't even charged with a crime
that is not an argument for letting
jacob blake off the hook that's an
argument for charging jacob blake with a
crime he should have been charged he got
off easy he was shot with his back
turned to the cops yeah his back was
turned to the cops because he was
reaching into a car with kids and a
weapon and resisting arrest after he
allegedly sexually assaulted a woman the
mother of the kids
we have a serious problem in this we
talk about how we need criminal justice
reform we do we do need criminal justice
reform we have a very serious problem in
this country with police leniency and
under incarceration
jacob blake should never get outside of
a jail
okay he's a bad dude who is committing
bad crimes and
he is now going to get
he did receive a payment from the state
because
of this kind of
grievance politics
because no one wants to touch this third
rail in american politics no one wants
to touch
race and the left is using rays and
exploiting race to their own evil ends
just tune in to msnbc joy reid
joy reid one of the most
honest people on msnbc in in that she is
honest about her radicalism she just
posted a tick tock
where she made clear the facts of the
kyle rittenhouse case or jacob blake or
whatever none of that matters
she hates white men and whatever white
men do is evil
it's car written house trial
it reminded a lot of people of something
something i just can't remember what it
was oh
the brett kavanaugh hearings in which
brett kavanaugh who had been accused by
a high school friend of committing
sexual abuse of her
cried his way through
the hearings to make him a permanent
member
and associate justice of the united
states supreme court
and his tears turned out to be more
powerful than the tears of christine
blasey ford which were the tears of an
alleged victim
but in america there's a thing
about both white vigilantism
and white tears
particularly
male white tears
really white tears in general because
that's what carrots are right
they carry out and then as soon as you
get caught
green water works
[Music]
white men can get away with that too and
it has the same effect
even as
the right tries to politicize the idea
that masculinity is being robbed from
american men by multiculturalism and
wokism
they still want to be able to have their
tears
you white men with your white tears now
joy read again because
i'm not sure the iq is is popping past
double digits
joy read reid
undermines her own argument she says
white male tears are bad and you saw
this with the brett kavanaugh case and
his tears mattered more than white white
women's tears in that in that case
christine blasey ford who was accusing
brett kavanaugh of all sorts of terrible
things even though christine blasey ford
couldn't even prove that she ever met
the guy
but then two seconds later she says but
white women's tears are terrible too oh
okay well then who cares about christine
blasey ford it's
pretty clear that joy reed just hates
white people
and
and she hates men and so she
specifically hates white men
and so in this in this case in brett
kavanaugh's case there was no evidence
against him whatsoever none of it and
some of the charges were so outlandish
that now the life doesn't even bring
them up like that woman who said that he
gang raped her
and she she was the client of michael
avenatti and they were both disgraced
very quickly so then they sort of went
away but even christine blasey ford her
story fell apart she had no evidence
whatsoever
doesn't matter
brett kavanaugh
faces a a completely unsubstantiated
serious allegation and then the minute
he defends himself the left attacks him
even more and makes fun of him for that
same thing here with kyle rittenhouse
the state the prosecutors have no
evidence against him whatsoever they
push a bunch of lies actually the media
push a bunch of lies about him then when
the defense knocks down those lies and
shows that all the evidence is on his
side he gets really worked up reliving
the trauma of this of this night and
then they make fun of him for that and
what it is
is just scapegoating right and the thing
about scapegoating is
you never realize that you're the one
doing the scapegoating no one throughout
all of human history has ever thought we
are scapegoating people right now the
people who scapegoat others always think
they're on the side of justice and so in
this case what the left does in this
country and the left is the dominant
regime in this country they scapegoat
specifically straight white men
it is the only group of people that you
are allowed
that it is socially acceptable to
discriminate against that it is legal to
discriminate against and actually that
it is encouraged to discriminate against
if joy reid or someone like joy reid
went on tv and started talking about how
awful black women are and how black men
are the bane of of existence then
she would be ostracized or eve face
charges of hate speech but but the only
group you're allowed to scapegoat are
straight white men and you're seeing
this play out
in brett kavanaugh
in the kyle rittenhouse trial
it's much bigger even we say that
self-defense is on trial here sure yeah
they say the second amendment's on trial
here sure but there's actually this much
bigger social problem which is the
increasing scapegoating of one specific
group of people
gets you so tense you really just need
some relief which is why i would
recommend you check out relief band
thanksgiving's coming up christmas and
new year's after that do not let nausea
get in the way of your holiday
festivities
whether it's because you have a little
too much champagne whether it's because
of your anxiety whether it's because
you're just sick relief ban is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband it has been clinically proven
to quickly relieve and effectively
prevent nausea and vomiting associated
with motion sickness
anxiety migraines i get a lot of
migraines hangovers morning sickness i
don't get a lot of morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more the
product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
provides all-natural long-lasting relief
with zero side effects for as long as
needed do not think that this is like
some cheap imitation that you buy for
ten dollars i was skeptical that this
would work i had them send me the
product
it 100 works it is incredible it's
backed up by
science it's the number one fda cleared
tool for anti-nausea as an anti-nausea
wristband as the holiday season
approaches there has never been a better
time to give the gift of relief and make
sure that your loved ones are nausea
free right now relief band has an
exclusive offer for our listeners go to
reliefband.com use promo code knowles
get 20 off plus free shipping and no
questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d dot com promo code
knolls for 20 off plus free shipping the
the scapegoating of straight white men
here and the the irrational rage the
phobia if you will against straight
white men is
uh something that is just part of human
culture you know my great friend spencer
clavin just did a terrific episode of
his podcast young heretics about this
specifically about the author renee
gerard and this this idea that
scapegoating is at the heart of human
culture that that our desires are such
that
the term is memetic desire that we we
desire things not because we d i don't
desire the leftist tears tumbler merely
because it's such a great tumbler i
desire it because other people desire it
as well we mimic one another's desires
and this this leads to rivalries and i
want this and no i want this and it
leads to a war of all against all and
the only way to resolve that is with a
scapegoat that's what you're seeing play
that's the deeper level of what's going
on here in the country when you see the
blm riots in the streets when you see
antifa hitting the streets when you see
the outrage about brett kavanaugh or
about kyle rittenhouse or whatever
the deeper thing here is this issue of
scapegoating
and the woke or the people doing the
scapegoating
some some of us who are not woke can see
that happening but the woke can't see it
happening because the people who
scapegoat never realize they're the ones
doing it they're always acting in what
they believe to be the name of
justice
and so
because this victim mentality is so
strong
many activists on the ground right now
are demanding special privileges the
co-founder of the portland resistance
gregory mckelvey
is just he just tweeted out quote
employers consider giving your black
employees a day or two off after the
written house verdict regardless of the
outcome it's going to be hard for black
people to work and it isn't fair to
expect them to
it's going to be hard for black people
to work all right cool with the racism
there david duke whoa i didn't realize
richard spencer was in the house
black people can't work and we shouldn't
expect black people to work talk about
the soft bigotry of low expectations
and talk about
talk about
mob violence and the rumblings of
potential mob violence
totally divorced
from reality
no
black people are involved in the kyle
rittenhouse case
none
if if one of if any of the people that
kyle written has defended himself
against that night were black kyle would
probably be in guantanamo bay right now
okay but they're not they were all white
people
and yet if you talk to the average
person about the kyle rittenhouse case
just the average
cnn viewer or msnbc viewer person who's
not paying that close attention
average person on the ground in kenosha
i bet you nine out of 10 people would
tell you that this was a case about race
that there were black people involved
there was a white supremacist who killed
a black guy
the the the mob violence the narrative
the the emotion the scapegoating
has
basically nothing to do with the reality
of what actually happened
with with that night in kenosha
or with kyle rittenhouse
himself
and now we're being told black people
can't go to work because of the trauma
of something that has nothing to do with
black people even if it did by the way
this isn't
this isn't the sort of thing we should
be indulging okay unless you think that
black people are sub-human and they
can't deal with
the suffering of this world like
everyone else does
unless you really believe that then we
need to stop indulging this stuff it's
not compassionate to anybody it's not
compassionate to black people it's not
compassionate for society at large it's
not compassionate to individuals cut it
out shut up stop grumbling everybody
needs to go back to work everybody needs
to stop focusing on everyone else's sins
everyone needs to stop focusing on
the the
worst terrible other person in society
in this case in our society would be the
straight white male
we all do it i'm not even exempting
myself from it this is a basic part of
human nature it's part of the fall okay
we live in an imperfect world
but we are not going to resolve that by
telling everyone to take days off of
work and go hit the streets and go
scream and yell about everybody and go
perpetrate mob violence and say no
justice no peace that's not going to do
it
to quote
a great
african-american who then i guess kind
of became a white american michael
jackson how about you take a look at the
man in the mirror and how about you ask
him to change his
ways it's like my if my friend andrew
clavin makes this point he says
the bigot is not necessarily wrong about
the other guy okay he's not maybe your
complaint about the polish or the
italians or the black people or the
whoever the white people maybe your
complaint
has some basis in reality but the thing
about the bigots is they're never right
about themselves they don't see that
they have many of the same problems that
they accuse other people of having now
speaking of racial politics and
employment
there's a spat going on at the white
house between
joe biden and kamala harris and it
centers around
aids to kamala harris accusing joe biden
of racism
it goes all the way back to kamala
harris herself accusing joe biden of
racism
so uh peter ducey
one of the few right-leaning journalists
in the white house briefing room he
asked jensaki about this
and said because there are all these
spats going on and accusations of racism
would joe biden
back kamala harris for president in 2024
or 2028 here's her non-answer
there are a few reports from over the
weekend that the vice president is
unhappy
can she expect the president's automatic
endorsement if she decides to run
herself in either 2024 or 2028
well first of all the president selected
the vice president because to serve as
running mate because he felt she was
exactly the person he wanted to have by
his side to govern the country she's a
key partner she's a bold leader and she
is somebody who has taken on incredibly
important assignments whether it is
addressing the root causes of migration
at the northern triangle or taking on a
core cause of democracy in voting rights
so that is who the president selected
i don't have any predictions of whether
she will run when she will run i will
leave that to her but i can tell you
that there's been a lot of reports out
there and they don't reflect his view or
our experience with the vice president
so speaking of racial politics don't
forget joe biden did not pick kamala
harris because of her unique individual
attributes he picked her because of her
genitals and the color of her skin and
he admitted that he said before he ever
picked her i am going to pick a black
woman
i don't care which black woman i'm just
going to pick a black so the primary
deciding factor for kamala harris's vice
president was nothing unique to her or
anything she had accomplished it was
just her skin and her sex and then he
had three prominent choices karen bass
who's a an actual communist and member
of congress
uh uh susan rice who is the fall man for
benghazi very unlikable candidate and
kamala harris who had at least run even
though she was so unpopular she dropped
out before anybody else in in 2020 and
so he had to pick kamala harris and now
and they he obviously detests kamala
harris she launched her campaign calling
him a racist and so there's no love lost
between these guys
and notice
the question jen saki didn't answer
namely will joe biden support kamala
harris either in 2024 or 2028
jen saki gives this very scripted answer
kamala harris is a bold leader
yeah you're not you can be bold and
terrible
you don't need to stalin was a bold
leader but
but
she never says she's a good leader never
says she's particularly effective never
says
that joe biden likes what she's doing
and never says that he will support her
very this this is that great
schadenfreude of watching the democrats
hoist themselves on their own pitard
identity politics is poison none of us
likes it we on the right fight against
it a lot the left uses it cynically
because they think it will help them
politically and then sometimes they get
caught up in that
that vicious cycle of identity politics
where the everyone's a racist and they
all just keep hurling that word at one
another now speaking of racial politics
there is a a parent a father who just
stood up at a school board meeting
and threatened
other parents who opposed critical race
theory
in schools
i've got over a thousand souls ready to
go we're not the board he should be here
so you can see finally the cops lead
this lunatic out of the room but you
heard that first line there goes i got a
thousand soldiers i got a thousand
soldiers if you oppose critical race
theory
in schools and he's conflating critical
race theory with just
talking about slavery or jim crow or
race in america which is which is a
a mistake that a lot of uneducated
people make but that's not what critical
race theory
is that guy should be arrested that guy
should not be permitted in society
you've got some parents showing up
saying keep crt out of schools keep
radical gender theory out of schools
they're being very polite they're
working within the system then you've
got this guy saying i've got soldiers
outside who are going to rough you up if
you exercise your legal rights that dude
if obviously if he were a white guy he
would be labeled a terrorist he would be
brought up on charges there would be a
trial and the media would dox him and
his whole family but because he's not in
the scapegoated class because he's not
in that category he's allowed to
threaten people with violence for
exercising their rights and no one says
boo about it
really not fair it's not fair too that
people have to pay such high prices at
the tank which is why
you should check out get upside i am
thrilled to introduce this incredible
app that is going to save you money at
the gas pump
just in the nick of time as as the
prices at the gas pump are going through
the roof right now our listeners are
making up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time they fill up all you
have to do is download the free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code knowles
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that is up to 50 cents
cash back do not
pay full price at the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside down the app
for free use promo code knowles to get
up to 50 cents per gallon cashback on
your first tank some people who drive a
lot
are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars in cash back per month
there's no catch there's only cash it
goes straight to your bank account or if
you prefer paypal or an e-gift card for
amazon and other brands just download
the free get upside app
use promo code noel's canon wles get up
to 50 cents per gallon cashback on your
first tank that is code
nulls also if you want to support the
fight to make your personal medical
decisions without government
interference
sign our petition against joe biden's
vaccine mandate hundreds of thousands of
americans have already signed the
petition
we need many more people to stand with
us to reach our goal of one million
please head on over to dailywire.com do
not comply to sign the petition today
we'll be right back with a lot more
welcome back to the show
speaking of murder murder has been
on our minds a lot recently obviously
the trial of kyle rittenhouse the trial
of kyle rittenhouse from the blm riots
are provoked by the shooting of jacob
blake and the blm before that and so
we've been talking about murder
and speaking of murder
ted cruz old zodiac himself has struck
again we're all focused on on kenosha
meanwhile we are letting this serial
killer senator just
slaughter
the secretary of homeland security
alejandro mayorkas during testimony
yesterday
how many children
have been in the biden cages in calendar
year 2021
senator i
respectfully disagree with
your use of the term cages fine you can
disagree with it how many children have
been in the biden cages i've been to the
biden cages i've seen the biden cages
how many children have you detained at
the donna tent facility and the cages
you built told kids how many children
have been in those cages senator i can
provide to you the following uh figure
that um
when and let me let me say that when a
child
i i don't
it's a simple question how many children
have been in those cages uh i i
respectfully am not familiar with the
term cages and to what you are referring
there are enclosures in which they are
locked in in which i took photographs
and put them out because you blocked the
press and didn't want people to see the
biden cages
stop it stop it senator he's already
dead don't do it anymore uh this is
a master class
in rhetoric
is anything going to come of this one of
the criticisms of senate testimony is
not a lot comes of it and that's
probably true the way our government
works now is that our legislators don't
have a ton of power other than
to expose what's going on in the
government and then it's up to us
through the elections through winning
the presidency and then hopefully
transforming the administrative state
through all of those things but what
what the senators can do here is expose
through testimony
what these
swamp creatures are doing and what
they're not doing and so the reason i
bring this up is not even to focus on
the kids and cages or immigration policy
it's to focus on how cruz
does not let mayorkas set the terms of
the debate
he is taking this term that the left
promoted the kids in cages that they
never stopped talking about during the
trump administration and he is using it
against them
he is hoisting them on their own pitard
and
mayorkas has the temerity to say well
i'm not i'm not familiar with that term
you're not familiar with the phrase kids
in cages the one that your side never
shut up about for four years you you
never heard that you don't know exactly
what we're referring to well senator i
never i just disagree with that term
okay you can disagree with it i don't
care what's the number and then mayorkas
basically just tries to filibuster and
tries to say well you know look it's a
complicated and this and well let me
back up and cruz won't let him do it he
cuts him off and says give me the number
this is not
complicated now
cruz knows
that mayorkas is never going to give him
the number
cruz knows that maorkus is not going to
feel any shame here cruz knows that
maorkus is going to continue his same
policy so what he realizes is the only
thing that republicans can get here
is to back
the democrat into a corner
to expose
him for what he is and expose what
they're doing for what it is
and then
to use that that that clip
that rhetoric
is going to be
the best thing we can get out of this
biden administration before the next
elections
and just while he's on the ropes cruz
finishes him off
secretary marcus you're not answering my
question so let me ask you this
in the past year has joe biden been down
to see firsthand the biden cages
senator i will again has joe biden been
down to see this facility
yes or no the president has not been
down okay no yes or no has kamala harris
been down to see
these detention facilities
she has not been down has any democratic
senator on this committee been down to
see the biden cages
i will once again disagree with your use
of terminology these facilities has any
democratic member of this committee
given a damn enough to see the children
being locked up by joe biden and kamala
harris because of your failed
immigration policies uh senator i cannot
speak to
the members of this committee
you don't know if any democrats have
been down there
to to oh i believe democrats have been
down to see this facility yes or no on a
facility whether they are members of
this committee i do not know
ted cruz did not need mayorkas there
to give this speech
ted cruz and this is something that
republicans should take notes about
ted cruz knew exactly what he was going
to say
before he walked in
majorcas was there as a prop as a toy
like
a cat with a ball of yarn ted the cat
mayorkas the ball of yarn
because
he knew where he was going he knew the
point
and he hit it and all too often
republicans play defense they think that
they're playing with
opponents who are who are engaging in
good faith and they're not and i think
cruz we haven't i'm not i haven't talked
to him about this point so i don't have
insider knowledge here uh but it would
seem pretty clear to me cruz knows
majorcas is not dealing in good faith
this is not an actual open exchange
where you're going to get useful
information he's just going to stonewall
so cruz is going to make his point
and then
mayorkas is going to fumble all around
don't let them set the terms of
engagement you want to talk about abused
terms here's an abuse term probably the
most abused term in the country
science
it's the most abused term in our
vocabulary and pfizer
just tweeted out about science pfizer
which is one of the
biggest one of the biggest companies in
the world hence the company pushing the
covet vacs
tweeted out a picture of an airplane
with a little message behind the
airplane
said no who's good at science
scientists
and pfizer tweets that says get on board
you know who's good at science
scientists you know who's good at
lobbying and propaganda multinational
corporations
with worth hundreds of millions of
dollars that's who's good at propaganda
and
lobbying you you've
the what the left has been telling us
from the beginning of the lockdown and
even before that is we need to just
trust the scientists
there are no scientists the scientists
are an illusion
what i see in that tweet is a
multinational corporation with a huge
amount of power and a huge financial
interest in getting us to take one side
of a public health question
when i look at dr fauci i don't see a
scientist i see a guy who does some
science but who is a politician who's
taken his his paycheck from the
government for his whole career highest
paid member of the federal government
when i look at al gore or joe biden or
prince charles or
any of the other
politicians public figures who are
pushing for science i don't they're
they're actually not scientists they're
just
they're just politicians
when i see public health i recognize
there's a scientific aspect but there's
also political aspect that's what public
means don't let them set
those terms uh someday if i if
if king knowles rules over the country i
think i may ban ban that word science
from
the discourse
okay and then who's the master of
politicized science
who's the master of it
dr fauci dressed up like a james bond
villain in a black turtleneck with an
oxford button down and a tweed jacket
over it opining from his garden about
how the american people are just too
too desirous of their own individual
rights
one of the things that to me was most
difficult to accept is that we put
together a good plan
for how we were going to try and dampen
down
the spread of infection early on
thinking that that was accepted by
everybody and then
the next day the president saying free
michigan free virginia
i didn't quite understand what the
purpose of that was except to put
this misplaced perception about people's
individual right to make a decision
that supersedes the societal safety that
to me
is one of the things that i think went
awry in all of this did you ever raise
that with president trump
you know i didn't have the opportunity
to raise it i was sort of like shocked
and then i didn't speak to him for some
time after that but
it was at that point
that i realized that i would have to
just get out there myself
and
say things that clearly were going to be
contradictory
the only thing that's missing from this
clip is dr fauci's stroking a fluffy
white cat on his lap these people they
have their liberty their rights they
talk about their rights they don't
realize
that dr fauci is their rights dr fauci
is their true liberty yeah yeah
he also admits that he's a coward by the
way because he says
i gave my advice to the president
and then the president didn't take it
and that was very bad and so the
interviewer says well did you tell the
president that no no i wouldn't no i
would never confront him face to face
man to man
no i would just stab him in the back on
tv when he's not looking that's what i
would do
that's the rate because he's a he's a
coward
and he has a
huge misconception a misperception of
his own political power
the point he's making about individual
rights has a grain of truth in it
it has a grain of truth in this if there
were
forget covid let's talk about a real
serious
gonna kill 90 of the people that get
infected with it type of super duper
virus
right a j not not a virus
where
the vast majority of people face
basically no threat from it and for huge
swats of people the infection fatality
rate is 0.003
and
but let's talk about one let's say that
70 of people who got infected with a
virus would die from it
and it were spreading like wildfire
throughout the country
would you support a vaccine mandate
yes you would yes you would of course
you would
would there be a legal basis for that
kind of a vaccine mandate yes there
there would be i think so in american
history it goes back to that case
jacobson versus massachusetts in 1905.
there is
a basis even before the official
founding of the country before the
constitution
george washington inoculating the
continental army against smallpox
the inoculation actually killed a lot of
people
yeah i think we all would if there were
a virus that were really going to kill
90 of americans and we're spreading we
would we would support those kind of
mandates
but that's not this virus
and this vaccine by the way is not
nearly as effective as they all told us
it was
so the particulars here i think are
being misperceived and being
misrepresented by people like dr fauci
and the biggest misperception
is
his role in the american government
because according to dr fauci's
perception
he should have ultimate power he's the
one who decides everything and your
individual rights and your state rights
and your rights through your duly
elected people even the rights of the
president
all are less important than doing
whatever dr fauci says which is why he
took it upon himself and presumed to go
on tv and undermine the duly elected
president left and right to say nothing
of undermining your individual liberty
politicians are always trying to exploit
science for their own political ends
there was a clip oh my gosh
the hits keep on coming with kamala
harris you think that you have seen the
most cringe inducing clip of kamala
harris and then right behind it there is
another one so kamala harris is at nasa
she's in a meeting at nasa and she
interrupts the meeting to ask if they're
super cool satellites and outer space
that are being used on all these amazing
uh experiments and for all these amazing
scientific purposes if they can be used
to spy on
neighborhoods to promote
tree
equity
climate adaptation strategies
can you measure um
part of that data that you're referring
to
and it's in ej's environmental
adjustments but you can also track
by rates
there are averages in terms of the
number of trees in the neighborhood
where people live
yeah forget about going back to the moon
forget about heading on up to mars and
exploring the rest of the solar system
and no what we need to do
is use these satellites in the sky to
spy on neighborhoods to see
how the how the trees are spread out in
the neighborhoods
that's that's going to be the use of
nasa the space agency this is a part of
the biden budget by the way is tree
equity
and of all the stupid programs in the
budget i actually have the least problem
probably with tree equity i like trees i
like beautiful neighborhoods i don't
mind that we're of all the ways to spend
money i don't mind planting trees in
poor neighborhoods
but this just shows you you make a
scientific advance you have the
scientific agency and the government
immediately says oh we're going to use
that to spy on people we're going to use
that to redistribute wealth
we're going to use that for our own
obviously political purposes
there's bad news for people
who don't like kamala harris which would
be most people
according to a new poll out from uh hill
and harris x
a majority of voters do not want joe
biden to run for re-election in 2024
61 of registered voters in a survey
conducted november 9th through the 10th
said that joe biden should not run for
president in 2024
devastating devastating numbers for a
sitting president
the only
people who think that biden should run
again
24
and there's another 15 who say that
they're unsure
but even if all of the ones who are
unsure
side with the ones who are sure and they
and they all want him to run again
still the overwhelming majority
say that joe biden shouldn't run again
so then you've got a big political
problem on your hands if you're a
democrat because your vice president is
the least popular vice president in many
decades if not ever
she's got a 28 approval rating right now
lower than dick cheney at the end of his
tenure as vice president after the iraq
war and after he shot a guy in the face
and after he was called darth vader for
years and she is still
measurably less popular than he is
so who's it going to be
as this heats up as people get more and
more disenchanted with joe biden as
kamala gets less and less popular you're
going to see biden and kamala continue
to snap at each other and you're going
to see more accusations of racism from
the kamala harris camp at joe biden and
you're going to see more mockery and
derision
hurled at kamala harris from the biden
camp it's happening right now
it has to they're in a
blood match against one another and the
the more they fight talk about mimetic
rivalry and a war of all against all
you're seeing that right now they're
they're just at a war with one another
eating each other alive and then the
question is if it's not going to be the
president if it's not going to be the
vice president who on earth is going to
step up
and be the nominee
is it going to be the secretary of state
anthony blinken not after afghanistan
is it going to be who else is buddha
judge i don't know is it going to be the
transportation secretary he's probably
going to be on paternity leave for his
for his presidential campaign who's it
going to be
who's it going to be
this is the one silver lining here
of these
this awful
[Music]
um ugly kind of politics of destruction
that you're seeing on the left
is you're you're watching them
destroy
themselves
there is no way
that joe biden can count on any kind of
popularity if he runs again he was just
in new hampshire trying to sell his
infrastructure bill so he walks up to a
a huge crowd with thunderous applause a
stadium just like donald trump is that
what happened no take a listen to the
reception for the president
so he's walking up
[Applause]
that's not what you're hearing is not
just droplets of water hitting stone
you're hearing just like one person
clapping
okay now you're hearing like four people
clapping
whoever did the advance for these guys
was not
not great at stagecraft because they
have a long way to walk up to the podium
like i'm counting the people applauding
it's
it's
three people
[Applause]
the leader of the free world the most
popular president ever got a gazillion
votes remember
[Applause]
still walking takes takes a while when
you're when you're joe's age
thank you
magnificent state
thank you uh thank you to both of you
for being here
this is the president of the united
states now you might say well he's in
you know some far-flung part of new
hampshire he's the president of the
united states he's the president of the
united states you would if he
did not have approval ratings in the 30s
at best
he would have a lot of people there to
welcome him
absolutely
pathetic that's the most the most
popular president ever who got the most
votes he got 80 bazillion votes in 2020
and if you suggest he got even one vote
fewer you're an insurrectionist
terrorist
okay i don't think he's that popular
i don't think and putting the previous
election aside i don't think if he runs
again he's going to get 80 gazillion
bazillion votes unless unless some more
water pipes burst at three in the
morning at the pole counting places in
georgia
speaking of the future speaking of
infrastructure jeff bezos has a
prediction
the eccentric billionaire amazon founder
just said at a recent event that he
believes that in the future most humans
will not live on earth and they will
think of planet earth as a protected
national park that they will only visit
as a tourist attraction he said quote
over centuries most or many of the
people will be born in space it will be
their first home they will be born on
these colonies they will live on these
colonies they may visit earth the way
you would visit yellowstone national
park
my question reading that quote
and observing the behavior of people
like jeff bezos bill gates
and the rest of them
do money and power inevitably make
people dumber
why is it that the richest and most
powerful people in history
seem so
stupid
first of all what he's saying is just
preposterous
the idea that we're all we're all just
going to leave earth whether it's
because of the sun monster you know
threatening us or
whatever or overpopulation or
global cooling or global warming or
whatever they make up next
we're all going to leave earth we're all
going to go to mars
or some other place a much much less
hospitable
incomparably less hospitable place and
then but but i guess actually the sun
monster didn't destroy earth because
we'll still go back as a tourist
attraction or something why is this
it's not just these tech billionaire
oligarchs it goes back
to the ancient pharaohs to rulers since
time immemorial who who just searched
desperately for immortality the elixir
of life
all of these fools errands
why is i think the answer is
pride i think it just comes down to
pride when you have everything when you
have every earthly desire satisfied when
you have your mistresses and you've got
your harem and you've got your yachts
and you've got your plane and you have
to go to outer space on a little tourist
voyage when you've got everything being
titillated and satisfied you just
you you indulge in fantasy the fantasies
that you will break these surly bonds of
earth and your your mortal bonds and
your natural bonds and that's not going
to happen but this is what takes people
down this is why the left doesn't see
what they're doing when they scapegoat
people this is why the left doesn't see
how unpopular their their agenda is
whether it's crazy racial theories or
gender theories or just the regular old
biden budget they don't see it they're
trapped in their own bubble they're
trapped in a system of pride which is
why we say pride goes before destruction
and a haughty spirit before a fall i'm
michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show a
blockbuster report claims the fbi
flagged all harassment in school
officials kindergarteners learn about
transgenderism and the rite house jury
continues its liberation that's today on
the bench bureau show give it a listen